Material scientist, Dr. Johnny Drain,...
...likes to wonder what things could be made of,...
...whether it's a smartphone screen,...
...the Michelin star restaurant dishes he's created,...
...or wanting to figure out how to replace cocoa.
This is the lab on the boat where the chocolate story begins.
Oh wow.
Come on board.
Thank you.
What's this?
So this is some of the ingredients...
...that we started developing the chocolate with.
Kinky salts?
Kinky salts.
That's various funky salts...
...from different places all over the world on my travels.
Dried shrimp.
That's not in the chocolate, is it?
That is not, and there's some raw cacao,...
...which we were trying to imitate at the very start.
But of all the things we try to find replacements for,...
...cocoa may not be an obvious one.
What most people don't realize about cocoa chocolate is that...
...about seventy percent of it...
...is produced in just two countries in West Africa, Ghana and Ivory Coast,...
...in a way that involves outsized water consumption,...
...so about 20,000 liters of water per kilo,...
...and that's way more than beef or soy or avocados.
And there are issues with labor in those parts of the world.
At a conservative estimate,...
...it's thought that 1.5 million children are on these cacao farms...
...working with their families predominantly.
Is this, however, not taking away income from countries that really need it?
Those countries do need that income,...
...and those hardworking farmers need to be supported,...
...but the state of the current cacao and chocolate industry...
...is such that those people are working on a dollar or less a day,...
...and it's not an equitable trade.